jetzt gerade gab es in bayern wieder
kontrollen bei metzgern und bäckern und
da wurden tatsächlich in jedem zweiten
kontrollierten betrieb mängel vor allem
hygienemängel festgestellt vor allem bei
wiederholungstätern
wir schalten wir live in die
traditionsbäckerei gruber zur chefin
frau gruber warum machen sie nicht
einfach mal sauber mein gott es ist so
ein theater wegen drei oder vier maus
gürtel in so einem riesen betrieb ja
weil ich flutscht mal was in den teig
die frage ist nur wann mache ich die
zeitmaschine aus wenn der kugelschreiber
einfliegt oder abgebrochen der
fingernagel oder ganze rumäne dann macht
es aus
dies ist ein bisschen oder eine schicke
rationieren eine andere frage wäre warum
erfahre ich als verbraucher der ich ja
die kontrolleure mit meinem steuergeld
bezahle nichts über solche jene menge
und mensch ernst der verbraucher er wird
noch von zu viel information nötig
verblüht außerdem weist jedoch gar nicht
wissen was wirklich drin ist in eurer
leberkäse
sie kostet weniger als hundefutter gaben
ganz ehrlich was soll mir denn schon
passieren in deutschland fehlen 1500
kontrolleure und selbst wenn er mal
einer kommt ganz sage ich heute meine
leute heute tun wir uns nach der
toilette mal die hände waschen
morgenstelle das wasser wieder ab hier
aus einem original kontrollbericht in
einer bayerischen bäckerei finden sich
verschimmelte nuss taschen und auf einem
weizenbrötchen die zitate pille eines
kleinsäuger und die kleinsäuger das kann
alles möglich ist sein vom feld townster
bis peter maffay jetzt immer ernsthaft
im schlimmsten fall können wir die
standard strafe auf die berühmte sind
350 euro veröffentlicht wird auch nichts
weil die angst haben dass wir klagen
also warum soll ich denn hier sauber
machen mir fehlte einfach der anreiz der
welt geht
das ist schade und daran wird sich auch
nichts ändern im neuen koalitionsvertrag
der kommenden groko steht dazu nur man
möchte dass die betriebe freiwillig die
kontrollergebnisse veröffentlicht
doch keiner mehr wasser dich mach doch
schoss so viel freiwillig hier schaut
hier ist ein mitarbeiter
der kontrolliert jedes einzelne mal auf
spuren von mäusekot geld da und weil
doch heute alles handgemacht sein sollte
ich hab sogar einen mitarbeiter der die
bios immer noch rollt wie früher sagt
demir welt geht da was glauben sie woher
der begriff sauerteig kommt geld und sie
wollen gar nicht wissen wie er unsere
käsestangen machen das möchte ich
wirklich nicht herr welke den frechen
ton denken sie sich sparen
die arag in original bayrisches punkt
seit 1746 das hier zum beispiel ist brot
von 1746 das verkaufen wir noch ist dass
der alarm wenn der kontrolleur kommt
bieten nein es ist schichtwechsel die
kakerlaken spätschicht konnte die
frühschicht hat schon feierabend geld so
servus kollegen bis morgen
auf der traditionsstrecke mein sofa
[Applaus]